das ist wirklich ein revolutionärer weg
zur kernfusion ein kleines deutsches
startup will großes vollbringen gelingen
soll das mit einer außergewöhnlichen
technik durch die fusion von proton und
bor
die laser induzierte trägheit fusion und
das geht nur bei absolut irrwitzigen
temperaturen und mit einer menge
zusätzlicher quantenphysik mit dabei
absolut renommierte top flüssiger also
wie weit ist diese super ausgeklügelte
verfahren jetzt bei klicks um science in
future hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
wir hatten ja hier bei pixum sunsim
future gerade ein video über eine neue
kern fusionstechnologie die vielleicht
schon in wenigen jahren einsatzfähig
sein könnte und es gab ein video über
quanteneffekte im makrobereich
verschränkte aber eben nicht teilchen
sondern kleine aluminium trommeln die
für eine sehr kurze zeit miteinander
verbunden sind und dasselbe machen also
die kernfusion ist auf dem besten wege
und die quantenphysik hält immer mehr
einzug in die unsere welt unsere
wirklichkeit und dieses projekt hier
trat beides absolut auf die spitze
denn hier findet nicht nur eine
kernfusion statt sondern es werden
weitere quanteneffekte genutzt um die
fusion unter den noch extremeren
bedingungen zu ermöglichen als ihnen
heute gängigen tokamak oder stellarator
reaktoren herrschen werden ein stückchen
erde auf der sonne eine co2 freie
energie lösungen eine idee um die
energieversorgung für die nächsten
generationen zu sichern
ein entscheidender beitrag zur globalen
energiewende ohne sicherheitsrisiko eine
saubere nahezu unerschöpfliche und
kontrollierte energiequelle das ist die
kernfusion genau diese ziele will das
münchner startup maazels fusion
erreichen und das schon in den nächsten
jahren viele millionen euro
investorenkapital wurden gesammelt die
jetzt für den bau eines ersten versuchs
reaktors bereitstehen es geht um die
fusionsenergie eine technik bei der die
prozesse die auch in der sonne ablaufen
nachgeahmt werden konkret geht es darum
nicht atomkerne zu spalten wie bei der
heutigen kernenergie bei der heutigen
kernspaltung bei den kernkraftwerken bei
der unmengen an
strahlung entstehen sondern die
kernfusion zu erreichen die
verschmelzung marie future setzt dabei
auf teile des atomkerns protonen und bor
atome eingesetzt werden soll eine
technik die so genannte laser induzierte
trägheit fusion genau daran arbeiten
forschungsteams weltweit schon seit
jahren so auch in kalifornien hier wird
einer der größten leser überhaupt ein
gesetz innerhalb von fünfzehn
nanosekunden transportieren 192 strahlen
eine energie von 4,2 megajoule von allen
seiten auf ein ziel das nur wenige
millimeter klein ist das ziel hier ein
kügelchen aus kunststoff oder premium
das mit gefrorenem schweren wasserstoff
gefüllt ist soll so zur inklusion
gebracht werden da steckt wirklich
gigantisches dahinter denn der riesige
leser soll dafür sorgen dass der
wasserstoff 50 bis 100 millionen alvin
heiß wird dabei würde er so stark
komprimiert werden dass er 100 mal
dichter wäre als bleibt denn dann würde
etwas ganz besonderes passieren so die
berechnungen der fachleute die
wasserstoffkerne müssten unter diesen
bedingungen zu helium verschmelzen
ein vielfaches der energie die vorher
für die zündung investiert wurde würde
dann wieder frei genau das ist die
grundidee der sogenannten laser
induzierten trägheit fusion
doch diese ist bis heute nicht mehr als
eine vision ein traum und das trotz
intensiver forschung und zahlreicher
forschungsgelder keine frage die
fusionsforschung hat viel potenzial wenn
ja wenn sie denn dann funktioniert denn
bei einer kante und wird so viel energie
frei wie bei keiner anderen
energiequellen bei der verschmelzung von
einem kilogramm wasserstoff zu helium
wird so viel energie geliefert wie ist
bei achtung 11.000 tonnen steinkohle der
fall ist derzeit gibt es zwei große
herausforderungen neben den großen
finanziellen mitteln die gebraucht
werden ist vor allem die technik nicht
ohne den wasserstoff atome verschmelzen
nicht einfach so zu helium die kerne
sind positiv geladen und es gibt eine
gegenseitige abstoßung das gas muss also
extrem erhitzt und verdichtet werden so
entsteht das plasma eine wolke aus
durcheinander fliegenden atomkernen und
elektronen in reaktoren mit form eines
donuts versuchen fachleute diese
teilchen mit hilfe von starken
magnetfeldern einzusperren
die rede ist vom sogenannten
karg oder den stellarator prinzip bei
dem der magnetischen einschluss des
plasmas eine wichtige rolle spielt
marvin fusion aber will die sogenannte
laser induziert trägheit fusion realität
werden lassen hierbei setzt man auf die
trägheit einer schockwelle im plasma
eine brennstoff kapsel nach der anderen
würde ihn sehr schneller abfolge
abgeschossen und gezündet werden das
ganze ist nicht ohne und bisher wird
solch eine forschung auch nur in groß
forschungsanlagen durchgeführt wie also
will das kleine deutsche startup marvel
fusion das schaffen dann gekündigt wurde
tatsächlich das bereits in den kommenden
zehn jahren ein entsprechender
demonstrator gebaut werden soll
und dieses ziel soll zudem auch noch
über einen besonders schwierigen weg
erreicht werden anders als die meisten
anderen projekte soll es hier keine
deuterium und tritium fusion geben also
das sind isotope von wasserstoff die
münchner wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben protonen und bor
ins visier genommen um genau diese zu
verschmelzen
doch dabei braucht es zehnmal höhere
temperaturen als bereits heute für eine
gewöhnliche fusion benötigt werden dass
dort ab das vor zwei jahren 2009/10
gegründet wurde hat also ein legendäres
ziel vor augen und dafür wurden absolute
renommierte wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftler aus der ganzen welt nach
münchen geholt unter anderem mit dabei
der stanford professor siegfried lenz
ein weltweit bekannter physiker und
fusions spezialist zur technologie von
marie fusion sagt er
dies ist ein völlig neuartiges
technologiekonzept mit disruptiven
potenzial es kann einen völlig neuen weg
zur fusion eröffnen der kommerzielle
energieerzeugung ermöglicht also
destruktiv heißt in diesem fall einfach
einen ganz anderen außergewöhnlichen weg
zu gehen der dann aber eben zur lösung
führt außerdem auch mit dabei florian
metz war vom renommierten massachusetts
institute of technology mit der zeit
wird nicht nur intensiv an der
weiterentwicklung der technik bietet man
suche auch nach einem standort für ein
erstes versuchskraftwerk hier sollen
dann einmal hunderte
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
arbeiten das konzept für die marvel
fusion kann man sich ganz grob
folgendermaßen vorstellen starke laser
schießen protonen auf das pellet also
die kapsel in der sich das büro befindet
teile der protonen fusionieren mit dem
bohr atom
und es entsteht beryllium dabei werden
alpha teilchen frei die gegen das
magnetfeld einer spule laufen ein paar
teilchen sind dabei teile des atomkerns
die aus protonen und neutronen bestehen
dabei geben sie ihre energie ab so wird
strom gewonnen der dann sofort ins netz
gespeist werden kann und das ist halt
wirklich revolutionär bei dieser
technologie wir bleiben nicht bei der
alten dampfmaschine denn selbst moderne
kernkraftwerke funktionieren immer noch
wie der wasserkessel auf dem herd die
energie wird gewonnen die exporte damit
wird wasser erhitzt und mit dem
wasserdampf werden dann turbinen
angetrieben also durch dass
verdampfendes wasser um die enorm hohen
temperaturen die normalerweise für eine
proton professoren benötigt werden zu
umgehen wird ein trick angewandt das
plasma wird in bedingungen gebracht bei
denen starkes quanten tunnelling
auftaucht um sich das besser
vorzustellen eine metapher dazu statt
einen golfball über ein hindernis zu
spielen fliegen die bälle einfach
geradewegs hindurch in der alltagswelt
so natürlich nicht möglich doch dieser
tunneleffekt ist in der physik ein alter
bekannter also der findet tatsächlich
statt das wäre so als müsste man über
amberg hätte aber eigentlich gar nicht
die kraft und deswegen geht man einfach
durch
man könnte durchgehend geht aber nicht
also vereinfacht gesagt geht es hier um
das jonglieren mit energie potenzialen
von atom doch klar ist auch in der
physik ist die wahrscheinlichkeit für
solche an durch tunneln eher klein wie
also will marco fusion dieses ziel
erreichen dazu äußert sich das start-up
nicht konkret der mitbegründer und
wissenschaftler carl georg schlesinger
bezeichnet es als einen zitat hoch
innovativen ansatz ein sehr starker
leser soll also einen sehr kurzen puls
abfeuern der extrem fokussiert auf einem
sehr kleinen fleck ist das target also
dieses pellet mit dem brennstoff enthält
laut schlesinger zitat nicht einfach
eine homogene gepresste kugel sondern es
besitzt eine sehr feine nanostruktur auf
atomarer skala dass klaas markt das
durch den laserbeschuss entsteht wird so
also in einem zitat stark korrelierten
zustand versetzt und genau durch diesen
quantenmechanischen tunneleffekt soll
dann die fusion von atomkernen
vereinfacht werden diese technik hat im
vergleich zu anderen verfahren so einige
vorteile
an werden war der person vom beau atom
und protonen keine störenden neutronen
frei die die reaktor wände angreifen und
eben strahlen stattdessen entstehen
direkt drei hoch energetische alpha
teilchen aus jeweils zwei neutronen und
protonen diese teilchen sind elektrisch
geladen und ihre energie kann so direkt
in elektrischen strom umgewandelt werden
und es ist wirklich ohne turbinen ohne
wärmetauscher revolutionieren die
teilchen müssen nur gegen ein magnetfeld
laufende in der schule wird so strom
induziert wenn die alpha teilchen dann
reichlich energie abgegeben haben werden
sie mit elektronen eingefangen und
werden zu unbedenklichen helium doch um
dorthin zu kommen sind extrem kurze
laserpulse mit hohem spitzenleistungen
im peter ward bereich also eine million
milliarden watt notwendig madl fusion
möchte dafür eine technik nutzen die
cerpos amplification kurz apps genannt
wird 2018 bekamen ein internationales
forschungsteam für die entwicklung
dieser technik den nobelpreis die
herausforderung hierbei die
laserleistung muss extrem hoch sein
doch dabei darf das verstärker medium
nicht zerstört werden um diese gefahr zu
umgehen wird der laserpuls zeitlich
gedehnt und dann wieder gestaucht also
echt es ist wirklich ein absolut
verrücktes verfahren was für tricks hier
alles angewendet werden damit das
funktioniert denn das funktioniert wenn
die verschiedenen frequenz bestandteile
des pulses verschieden lange wege
zurücklegen müssen das lässt sich mit
der hilfe optischer gitter erreichen am
schluss werden alle frequenzen wieder
zusammengesetzt wow das klingt wirklich
ziemlich ausgeklügelt aber auch ziemlich
kompliziert getüftelt wird beim asus
yusen also an einem neuen leser der im
besten fall zehn schuss pro sekunde
abfallen kann erst ergebnisse dazu
werden in drei bis fünf jahren erwartet
erst dann wird sich in experimenten
zeigen ob das deutsche startup
realistische ziele verfolgt erst dann
also bekommen wir eine antwort auf die
alles entscheidende frage ob die idee
hinter diesem reaktor wirklich
funktioniert die quanteneffekte die
benötigt werden wurden bislang de facto
nämlich nur in computersimulationen
nachgewiesen genauer gesagt in zwei
voneinander komplett unabhängigen
simulationen das ist den forschenden von
marvel zwischen wichtig an dieser stelle
zu betont spricht dieses projekt
wirklich ziemlich waghalsig doch leist
auch es steckt mehr dahinter als eine
kühne vision denn eine proton bohr
fusion mit hilfe eines lesers im labor
ist bereits gelungen das erste mal vor
16 jahren und seitdem konnte stück für
stück eine größere ausbeute an alpha
teilchen gemacht werden die technologie
die magischen nutzen will hat einen
readynas level 2 dabei handelt es sich
um eine skala mit der die reife von
technologien bewertet wird sie reicht
von 1 bis 9 und 2 heißt das dass
wissenschaftliche prinzip beobachtet und
beschrieben wurde und es pläne gibt für
die darauf aufbauende technologie
wir können also extrem gespannt sein
sehr extrem gespannt also ich finde es
wirklich eins der fantastischsten themen
im bereich wissenschaft die es überhaupt
gibt alle energieprobleme auf einen
schlag gelöst großer durchbruch bei der
kernfusion in den usa hier ist man auch
an der innovativen lösung der kernfusion
dran also anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
diesen kanal klicks um science im future
einfach hier unter dem video oder jedem
anderen video auf dem abo button klicken
vollkommen kostenlos übrigens muss man
ja manchmal noch mal sagen also
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran